from Asia tonight now the president of
South Korea saying that sanctions on
North Korea simply will not be eased
based on the hope of talks over its
nuclear program his statement aimed at
tamping down concern over a reported
offer from kim jeong-hoon that hints at
a breakthrough on one of the world's
most dangerous matters correspond to
Richardson reports tonight at the State
Department senior US officials and world
leaders are diminishing expectations for
possible nuclear negotiations with North
Korea this is just the beginning
I believe we are not yet at a situation
where we can be optimistic South Korea's
president says sanctions will continue
against North Korea even as North and
South Korea meet next month at a summit
Secretary of State Rex Tillerson is
still pushing countries to cut off trade
with the north as for North Korea's
offer to negotiate its nuclear program
senior officials and analysts say
they've seen this approach before this
is not our first rodeo we've been on
this before we've had eight
international agreements with North
Korea all of which failed so I think
it's it's good to be deeply skeptical
although we can should try again in the
1950s with the help from the Soviet
Union North Korea began its nuclear
program insisting it was peaceful in
1985 it signed on to the nuclear
non-proliferation treaty promising not
to develop nuclear weapons but by 1989
satellites discovered evidence of a
weapons program the North Korean
PlayBook really consistent through three
generations is is really a two-page
playbook it's provocations and threats
and even attacks and then the second
page is charm offensives in 1994 North
Korea threatened to withdraw from the
non-proliferation treaty in an agreement
with the u.s. that year Pyongyang
committed to freezing its plutonium
weapons program in exchange for aid
years later the u.s. again discovered
evidence of weapons development by 2002
the US says North Korea admitted to
having a clandestine nuclear program
then North Korean leader Kim jong-il
ejected international inspectors from
the country months later he withdrew
from the non-proliferation treaty years
of negotiations with regional countries
followed and in 2006 North Korea
detonated its first nuclear bomb as the
u.s. negotiates these security issues
there are economic pressures between the
allies president Trump's proposed
tariffs on steel would hit significantly
unlikely South Korean producers the u.s.
and South Korea are also renegotiating
their free trade agreement 1 the
president has called horrible for the
United States bill rich Thank You
Richardson from the State Department